hello in this video I'll talk about
lactose operon now what is an operon so
simply we can think of Oberon is a set
of genes controlled by a single promoter
let's say we have a promoter marked here
in black and this gene one two three and
four is under the control of the same
promoter that means expression of all
these genes are dependent on this you
need fight promoter then this kind of
arrangement or this kind of mechanism of
gene expression is known as a operon
system simply lactose operon would be
used to produce the genes that are
required for lactose metabolism in
e.coli so and all these genes by the
name we can understand that all these
genes would be under our control of
single promoter before we go to the
details of it let's just simply try to
understand what does Lac operon does so
let's say you like rice simply like you
the e coli the prefer food is or the
preferred nutrient source is glucose if
you give if you're having a choice
between rice and chapati and a bacteria
having a choice between glucose and
lactose you would definitely choose rice
and the bacteria would choose glucose
simple now bacteria would choose glucose
when there is an option let's say in the
environment there is no option to get
glucose at that moment so lactose is
only alternative food at that situation
so in order to perform lactose
metabolism lac operon genes need to be
turned on such that lactose could be
also metabolized to get necessary energy
sources and that is all about lac operon
clearly we can understand that lac
operon is not activated all the time
because bacteria prefers group glucose
over
lactose and bacteria uses glucose as a
primary nutrient source not lactose so
all the time bacteria don't need the
genes to metabolize lactose so the
default state of this operon is off but
it is an inducible operon that means in
presence of lactose the lac operon genes
are turned on and the necessary enzymes
required for lactose metabolisms are
produced so clearly
lac operon is an inducible operon now
let's just take a look at the genes that
are under the lac operon so we have
lacked C Lac Y and lack a under a common
promoter now the lag z gene give rise to
PETA galactosidase whereas lac y gene
give rise to lactose permease and lack a
genes give rise to galactose it is trans
as it is now the lac y gene product
permease is important to bring in
lactose even if lactose is not present
in the male in the media huge amount of
glucose is present some amount of
transcription from these genes always
happen and thereby few permease enzymes
or few the beta galactosidase would be
there so the permease brings in lactose
from the environment and this lactose
could be broken down into glucose and
galactose more simpler form and which is
easy to digest for the bacteria and this
happens by the action of the enzyme beta
galactosidase
which is a product of lacked c gene now
lactose could also be converted to an
isomer form which is known as a low
lactose and that could be also triggered
by the enzyme beta galactosidase we
would look at in the subsequent part
that what are the important role that
para galactosidase permease etc play on
this
before that let's just look at few
critical situations now let's say in the
environment only glucose is present so
it's a favorite food of e.coli so
definitely it doesn't need to metabolize
lactose or doesn't even need to think of
metabolism metabolizing lactose so we
can expect that lac operon is off but
how it is off so the lactose operon
upstream to the lactose operon there is
another gene which is under a control of
separate promoter known as lac I now the
lac I gene product is basically a Lac
repressor now in absence of glucose lac
repressor can bind to the operator
region of the lac operon and don't allow
the polymerase to bind to the promoter
as a result none of the lac operon genes
could be transcribed and it makes sense
because in presence of glucose the
bacteria don't need to think of lactose
breaking down so it would utilize
glucose as a primary nutrient source not
thinking of lactose so the operon status
in presence of glucose is off think
about a situation where there is only
lactose present glucose is not available
in the environment then what happens is
that lactose which is getting n which is
getting inside the bacterial cell is
converted to an a lactose by the
activate by the activity of the enzyme
PETA galactose it is which is a lag z
gene product now a low lactose would
inhibit the lac repressor as a result
lac repressor cannot bind to the
operator region and cannot suppress it
as a result RNA polymerase can bind and
give rise to transcription of the lac
operon genes and thereby be Rogalla
Chrissa days permeate and galactose I
trans acai lays all these necessary
lactose metabolizing products would be
produced
but this regulation is not so
straightforward it has the complexity is
added at the level of another important
molecule which is known as catabolized
activator protein which is a cyclic EMP
dependent protein so whenever there is
glucose cyclic EMP level is low
now when cyclic EMP level is low
caribou light activator protein is
inactive and at the same time you have
to understand that in presence of
glucose lac repressor is active lac
repressor would bind to the operator
region and don't allow the RNA
polymerase to bind and also for optimum
recruitment of the RNA polymerase can
calculate activator protein or cap is
essential so when cap activity is low
optimally the RNA polymerase cannot be
recruited into the lac promoter now
think of a situation when only lactose
is present then first of all our lac
repressor is suppressed at the same time
since we have less glucose cyclic AMP e
is high and the catabolic activated
protein is activated so it can optimally
recruit RNA polymerase and as a result
Lac operon is turned on now let's come
to a complicated situation in the
environment both glucose and lactose is
present and this is sim similar to the
example that I given you that you like
both rice and you like rice but you have
option of both rice and chapati so
definitely you would prefer rice and it
would eat rice then if the bacteria's
option of glucose and lactose bacteria
would prefer glucose but how does it
happen at a molecular level so at this
situation we can understand when lactose
is present lactose is converted into a
low lactose and as a result the lac
repressor is inhibited
but at the same time when so lack
repressor is inhibited now theoretically
now RNA polymerase is free to interact
with the promoter and transcribe the
genes but at the same time what happens
is glucose level is high so cyclically
MP level is low as a result cannibalized
activator protein is not that active and
it cannot optimally recruit it cannot
optimally recruit RNA polymerase into
the promoter as a result the
transcription from the lac operon genes
does not occur so also in presence of
glucose and lactose when both are
present lac operon genes are turned off
they remains in a dormant state and
glucose is used as the principal
nutrient for metabolism and this
phenomena is known as caribou light
repression simply it means whenever you
have simple nutrients use the simple
simple nutrients and don't bother to
break down complex nutrients to make for
the simple and simple nutrient so
glucose is way more simpler than the
lactose that's why bacteria would
readily prefer glucose over lactose even
both are present in the media so that
concludes the video on lactose operon I
hope this video was informative and if
you like my video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you